How is it that charge can be both attractive and repulsive?
How does it know when to behave in which way?
Well, charged objects can either be positive or negative.
This is totally different from mass, which when we described an object's mass we said 5 kg.
We didn't have to say +5 or -5. It doesn't make sense to talk about a negative mass.
And the key thing to remember with charge is that opposite charges attract each other
but like charges repel.
Now this is really amazing.
Now the key thing with charges is that opposite charges attract and like charges repel.
Let's say you have these two charges and you are somehow able to hold them in your fingers.
Right now, there exists some force between these two charges.
If I let go and allow these charges to move,
I want to know what will the charges look like after I allow them to move.
Will they look exactly the same like nothing happened?
Will they come together and be really close?
Will they fly apart from each other? Choose the best answer.